[musique]
aller
les adolescents
[musique]
moi
Ouais ouais ouais
quoi
Oh oh oh
ooooooooooooooooooooooooo
Ouais ouais ouais
dieu
A part ça, j'avais l'habitude de
Je visais une voiture manga, donc si vous écrivez un manga comme celui-ci, qu'est-ce qu'une voiture manga ?
L'idée de base est de continuer
avait
moi
bap
Ana
moi
quoi
concernant
[musique]
Et quand j'ai dit ça, Mario est sorti à l'intérieur.
Les bandes dessinées de Mickey Mouse sont dans les bandes dessinées
Mikimasu a grandi dans les films et dans cette animation.
Si vous faites cela, Mario et Kazelda sont également de ce jeu vidéo.
moi
[musique]
vaudou
la toile
bl n
Ouais ouais ouais
gelée
rare
quoi
[musique]
DJ
Livre Uzu
re produit
gelée
quoi
dl
Oh oh oh
gelée
moi
Oh oh oh
Grand boom
re voir
21 Yamimaru
4 Mammamiya utilise ton numéro wah ah ah ah 6 personnes
fba pcl westwale renouvelle sumocha drive ipg
blog de jeu
croiseur norberg john lee talonneur
[musique]
voiture
moi
[musique]
[applaudissements]
gelée
Oh oh oh
[applaudissements]
aucun
quoi
[rire]
Je pense que Mario est un frère aîné normal et non un super-héros.